good morning thank you for those of you
have joined me here today
we're going to talk about ai and ai ops
this morning we're having a little bit
of fun with it so
you know i'd like this to be interactive
as possible and i'll have an opportunity
at the end for you to offer your own
feedback and your own thoughts as we get
through this and for those of you with
some interesting ideas i've got a few
hats to throw at you
so if i can keep you awake for the next
half an hour hopefully i'm doing well
and we can move this through
so who am i
i'm the global field ceto for mirantis
um i've been stuffing around with
technology for the last 20 odd years
building enterprise systems everything
from public cloud solutions to helping
companies design financial systems
i'm my colleague nick chase who's not
with us this morning helped me put
together the slides and the deck that
we're going to use today he is more of
the expert on this topic than i can ever
hope to be
but i'll try and do my best to
do it justice
so we're going to talk a little about
what is the current scenario when we're
talking about operations today and what
is the problem we're trying to solve
a little bit of background what is aiops
what does it mean to us some of the use
cases and i'd love to hear from you when
we talk about these use cases where you
see this going
i've obviously got strong opinions on
this i'm sure everybody else does
obviously limitations
you know tldr we're not quite there yet
and then what can we do now to get us
there to prepare the way for us to
implement effective ai ops as we go into
the future
so the current scenario as we see it
what is operations today what are we
looking at right now
for most of us it's some combination of
humans at keyboards
working shifts
dealing with problems as they arise
we are seeing more and more intelligent
automation come in
companies like ours and many of us are
implementing automation as deeply as
much as possible
but it's still
highly highly reliant on humans
delivering work
and obviously humans are fallible we all
know that
even more so than the machines we look
after for a living
you know the problems that we're dealing
with on a day-to-day basis this
shouldn't be new to anybody here i would
hope um if you've been in this opening
for an openstack world for a while you
know we're dealing with network
disconnects maintenance updates software
bags software bugs and more software
bugs i mean that's most of our livings
here
stupid things like certificate timeouts
how do you deal with the certificate
timeout in time
you know security breaches the obvious
things this is what the state of
operations is today
part of that is we're so reliant on
people
being available to deal with these
challenges when they arise
i look at companies that are trying to
deliver operations as a managed service
and i look at the challenges that our
customers have um the people i talk to
in the industry
just keeping staff available keeping
staff on 24-hour shifts you know one of
those determinations we see is to handle
a single 24-hour shift 365 days a year
for one
sme so one subject matter expert i need
seven individuals
give people time off
holidays you know not have people
working 12 13 14 hour shifts
because more shifts you work the more
tired you are the more mistakes we make
um
itel
how many of you here have dealt with
idle within your lives
show of hands because idle is the bane
of my life
i mean i've been dealing with it from
the early days this is all the things we
have to take into account when we're
talking about the implementation of
operation services
so what would be nice where could we
take this
the dream vision is we automate and use
intelligent automation ai ops or machine
learning to handle all these tasks that
quite frankly are fairly routine
but need to be dealt with by humans
and the more we can take out humans from
dealing with routine tasks in those
day-to-day operations the more likely we
have that those smart intelligent people
can be adding value to the business as
we work for it
that's really the key value as i see it
of the move towards intelligent
automation ai ops and machine learning
within our operations environments
obviously there are many many other
applications where ai can start to bring
value to us
we won't get into code we won't get into
all of those other options but let's
just focus now on what ai ops is
actually to us
so what is aiops
at the end of the day operations are
just actions that we take
they're just
a reaction to a event
but the real question is how is the
decision made to do what and when
it's very easy for us as humans who have
been training at something for
30 odd years have degrees in engineering
have broken the systems multiple times
and learned from our failures
but how do we teach a machine to do that
today all of these decisions are made by
humans
pretty much all of these decisions even
the process of coding it manually to go
through a series of steps is still done
by humans which means it's fixed by and
large or involves a human in the cycle
so at some point the system stops and
asks for input
we want to get away from that
we want to get a way into a position
where the machines can make the
decisions on our behalf so that we're
not getting that text message or that
slack or that phone call at three
o'clock in the morning or we don't have
to have people working at three o'clock
in the morning away from their families
children dealing with the real world
so the question is what is ai versus ml
so aia is coming today
technically there are three categories
i'm going to talk about to talk about
weak ai and strong ai
weak ai is just intelligent behavior
modeled
it's if then
statements maybe a couple of case
statements for those of you who can
remember writing case statements
it's a couple of if then statements what
we're doing is we're modeling a response
to a determined set of problems
strong ai is where the machines start
being able to make decisions in their
own right now i'm grossly simplifying
this
for the purpose of today but it's still
fairly hypothetical
we don't really have true strong ai
in the industry at all yet it's being
developed
siri alexa all of those things are weak
ais they are
programmed responses to a certain
determined set of information now
machine learning is a subset of ai it's
a feeder into
more advanced ai models
the big thing about machine learning is
we're taking a set of data we're
providing a formula we are providing a
formula we're not letting machine
determine a formula for us at this stage
and we're building a trend from that
that trend will allow us to make
decisions based on that data
that's the progression that we're
talking about
so
ai it's literally
machine intelligence it's machines
trying to mimic what we as humans do and
that cognitive capabilities that we're
able to take to make a call on something
today they're typically considered
expert systems
we train them to answer these specific
questions the siri or the alexa type
examples there are others
and
we are reliable on training them or
reliant rather on training them with
fallible human logic you know the
basic
simple step logic the sean is human
humans are mortal therefore sean is
mortal
my liver tells me that definitely
sometimes i feel more immortal than i am
but i'm not and as i mentioned ai is a
superset of ml and today we're going to
focus more on ml
um to try and understand how we can take
ml forward in our way of thinking about
this as we go ahead
so as i mentioned machine learning is a
determination of a trend line in data so
that we can have
computers make decisions on our behalf
so we're looking at a data set
we're saying there are pretty
standardized trends we apply a formula
to the input data and we'll get a graph
most data that we deal with today most
of what we're dealing with making
decisions on alerts is straight line
trends
we know a plus b equals c
response
obviously do we need machine learning
for that probably not because we already
know that a plus b equals c
where it starts to get more interesting
is where we have more complex data sets
where more complex formulas based on
more complex data inputs can change a
graph
and we start looking at how we can
compound information across multiple
different
systems and this is where machine
learning starts to get a lot more
interest to us so if we look at an ai
and an operations world that we're all
in today it's the correlation components
it's dealing with
small tiny changes that a human would
not see
because
we just can't hold that much information
in our heads
but the machine over time can be taught
to pick out those little nuggets of
information
bring them back to the formula and apply
them over a broader spectrum of
information
that allows us to make a prediction of
what could go wrong
now
obviously if we can't
predict what would go wrong or can't
build a formula to pick the correct data
to predict what was going to go wrong
well we probably can't train a machine
to do that
and this is where we get into where the
problems of what we're trying to achieve
today
so
how do we do this
typical machine learning
of course i'm saying typical
we decide an algorithm we pick an
algorithm we pick something that we're
looking for we have to have an end point
in mind
we take that algorithm and we train the
model on predetermined fully understood
training data
now this is where it can get really
interesting because once again the human
factor comes in
we might think that that data is fully
understood
but it could bring in anomalies that can
make a mess of our model i was going to
say differently there
we then have to test that model so we
train the model we test that model by
feeding in data that we know is either
good or bad that's going to lead to a
specific result
now the problem with that once again
comes
how sure are we about that data
now what i want to bring in in a second
and i'll talk about what how we apply
this in the real world
but the final step is take that model
and at least start by alerting
we have to have an event so the model
essentially just gives us an output
event an alert
which we can then action
those actions are the next generation
for us right now where those actions
that we're going to take out of our ml
models are really just predetermined
we're going to go
yes disc is going to run out in 24 hours
let's add more disk
we haven't yet reached the point where
we can have machines decide well
let's not add more disk let's remove
some data that's a much more complex
decision tree that we would like to get
to with the machines but right now we're
focused on an initial stage of let's
just find the problems
so in the real world
it's much the same it's a repeat of the
previous slide just say differently we
take that algorithm now by now we have
gone through this process of building
our algorithm modifying our algorithm
probably a hundred thousand times
because we're going backwards and
forwards
constantly iterating here
we're going to train that model so
a company can deliver you an ai solution
one ml ops solution
based on a formula that they've trained
on their data
they've got to bring that into your
specific environment and train it on
your specific data sets
so there's no such thing as a silver
bullet of here's the ml tool for
everyone and it'll start working
tomorrow morning blankly if somebody
walks in and says here's an ml tool for
monitoring your network and it'll be
working for you by tomorrow morning
i would be super skeptical
because the reality is every single
environment is different there's some
great companies out there doing really
interesting things with machine learning
but all of them and all of the good ones
when they come on board it's a six to
eight to 12 week training period before
they will commit to any results
we then have to go through the process
of testing the model
against data that's known good or known
bad within your environment so
how do you take your environment and
actually simulate an outage
you got to go and create an outage to
test your model
you've got to be able to do that so that
can be quite disruptive in getting us
ready for this
and then obviously once we've got a
working model
we've got to constantly monitor it and
check it and make sure it is responding
the way we expect it to respond
okay
so digging into some of these use cases
ultimately the way we're looking at it
the use cases are built around three
core domains
we've got detection
prevention and remediation
from a detection point of view it's a
lot of what i've been talking about is
how do i find out what's wrong with my
system
what am i trying to look for what are my
formulas focusing on within my
environment and it's everything i
mentioned earlier those network outages
it's
i have a network failure in
my
branch office that it's just packet loss
whenever that happens i'm noticing in
the data center i'm getting a slowdown
on processing of applications what's the
correlation between those two
is there even a correlation how do i
look at that across this whole domain of
all of this to make sure that i'm
getting an effective answer that i can
respond to
that's the detection component
the other big area around detection is
the aggregation of smaller issues
it's looking at issues within a much
more complex system kubernetes logs open
stack logs
um you know just look at the nova api
logs in verbose mode and the sheer
volume of what's going on there and
finding those little nuggets that you
can correlate in an effective way over
the last 48 hours without building
massive elastic search
solutions so it's all of that bringing
all of that together in an intelligent
way so that we can respond to these
things
one of the most interesting and probably
the most current application of
real-world
ml machine learning ai ops is in the
intrusion detection space
there are some great companies out there
doing some really interesting stuff
where they have built solutions that are
looking at all the data within a network
environment
correlating that and looking at the
patterns being used to determine
security intrusion so it's a
non-traditional way of looking at
intrusion it's not just looking at is
someone trying to you know a certain
series of packets very quickly
doing a port scan
it's
has the pattern changed within the
network of the standard networking
traffic now we start getting really
interesting on what we could do because
if i can take that
and i can respond in real time by just
throttling
that particular source
or even cutting it if i need to
i can respond far faster and far better
and prevent intrusions
same
with the example of packet loss if i can
determine that the packet loss is
actually causing the slowdown inside my
database engine because of a kubernetes
app that is failing to communicate
correctly i can kill that process and
speed up everything else that's the
beauty of where we can go with this
and that's where we start talking about
prevention
prevention is maintenance it's the
general maintenance that we all do every
day um our operations guys go in on big
open stack clusters and go and check
do we have enough database tables left
do we have enough storage space left are
the logs filling up the drives um
you know are we hitting limits on
connectors
all those things are easily changed if
we know they're happening but they also
take up resources
if we just turn them all the way up all
the time so now we can be much more
dynamic about our resource utilization
workloads we've all heard about the
dream of really using spot instances on
amazon
but the reality of spot instances is
unless you have something intelligent
dealing with them
most of the time they don't really save
you very much
but if you can intelligently determine
when spot instances are going to be
available through the prediction data
from ml
now we can start to take more value of
those things
remediation is the area where
i feel long term most of the work we
need to do is going to be
the detection side is data science this
is a known problem we've been doing this
for a long time most of us understand
that you can correlate data and
most of the work right now and the
intelligent work that's being done in
machine learning is happening in that
space
the remediation is where i think the
biggest and most interesting work is
going to be done and i say going to
because i don't personally know of
anybody who is doing much in the
remediation
true
machine learning or ai based remediation
we want to get to this point where we
can kill unused workloads find the
alternate traffic routes
more importantly we want to get to the
point where we're not reliant on a human
being in the path of the decision-making
process
or at least a human is just an approver
for a decision-making process
now as the way of getting there
i know the way we're looking at
determining and building this out is
that we will have humans
approve decisions until such time as we
trust the machine
you know we can get into long stories
about ghosts in the machine here but
ultimately that's where we're going
now let's talk a bit about the
limitations
i've mentioned some of these already
we have limited inputs we
are a big part of the limitation
the next slide we'll get to that
but right now
what we need to train these models is an
enormous amount of data
that enormous amount of data is very
hard for us to understand for us to find
what all the parameters we have to deal
with are
network traffic i mean i i grew up in
the networking world i can remember when
a large network was 40 or 50 nodes
i'm not talking data center networks i'm
talking wide area networks data center
networks are a different story
nowadays
you know every network input is our cell
phone that's part of the network how do
i how do i deal with that huge volume of
different parameters and bring that into
a system
that's we've got to get our heads around
that
we have so many systems providing input
prometheus
log systems kubernetes
all of these systems we've got to get
our heads around what are the parameters
that are important to that so we can
train our models
we need access to more in-depth info
you know many of us here at these
events are infrastructure people we
think about everything from the point of
view of infrastructure but
infrastructure is only a small part of
what we need to look at and have data
from
to effectively impact
workload uptime we need all that
information from inside the workloads
tracing as an example so how do we bring
all that information in
we're deciding to talk about data sets
that we have to store
we need you know in some cases we need
bigger systems to run the ai and ml
component than we're actually running
the workload at what point does this
start to become daft
we are a problem
okay we're trying to teach a machine to
imitate us we can't even teach ourselves
a lot of the time
so
we learn
more over time the same way we're trying
to teach these machines
we can then add the parameters how do we
teach the machines to add these
parameters is the big question and
that's
the
problem we need to solve
the volume of historical data needed
is quite frankly one of the biggest
challenges that we're seeing in the work
that we're doing at the moment
to train models
how do we deal with things like
distributed learning how do we bring
that information together in a
structured way again there's some really
interesting work being done
there's some great startups here in
germany who are very much focused on the
distributed learning model companies
like flower and others
so
really cool work happening in that space
i'm very excited about what's coming
there so i'd love to hear from you guys
what you're seeing
and of course
there are many things we haven't even
thought about yet
routines can't tell us everything okay
some things we as humans just infer
based on our cognitive capabilities
and
we don't really know how ai
works
we can't really explain this thing you
know we can look at the outputs but in
many cases we don't really
we can't really decipher neural networks
we don't really understand how these
things are coming together how we're
training these things i'm sure you've
all heard the stories about biases
neural networks you know how do we deal
with biases we are inherently biased as
humans how do we as a biased individual
train a machine that we don't understand
based on our intelligence that we don't
understand
to remove bias
this is the biggest challenge which
we're going to have moving forward to
true ai
and i'm talking about true ai here as
opposed to machine learning
less neural components
and ultimately this is still a black box
i threw that image in you know we need
to untangle that we need to untangle the
neurons we need to try and understand
where we're going and we need to be very
deterministic about this
causality is still in its infancy you
know we're still trying to understand
this
we can't necessarily explain why
something causes something else
there are there is work being done in
that space the library such as do y
there's more and more information
starting to become available within the
public domain and i think what we're
going to see is we're going to see the
acceleration of this learning because of
the fact we can do this in the open
source domain
bring it back to why we're here
this causality component is key
to that remediation
if we cannot learn to understand
causality we won't be able to do
remediation
and for many of you know how difficult
it is just to teach people to go through
the process of doing proper
troubleshooting now we've got to train
the machines to do that and that's the
that's the challenge we have for the
future and i think that's the most
exciting thing we've got to do for the
future
so what do we do
now
what do we do to help us get to this
hypothetical
blue sky future where the machines are
running everything and
skynet has arrived
and hopefully without the killer robots
let's see
i'm going to keep this really simple
we need to start focusing on building
out as intelligent automation as
possible
we need to make that automation
available
as widely as possible so the same way we
automate the same way we build tools in
the open source domain
we need to build and make that
automation available to everybody so
that everyone can have input to that
let's build this automation in the
public domain
let's not forget though we need these
intelligent humans as part of the mix
and we need to understand how humans are
going to interact with our automation
that's a core
function here
if we cannot get the machines
to include the humans
the machines can't learn from us
so as we build out these technologies we
have to focus on how do we interact
better
with the meat puppets
all of that is built around strong
alerting strong data collection and
creating a environment where we can
safely collect all of this data
and potentially anonymize it so others
can get use of it and this is where
things like distributed learning comes
in we can learn in multiple environments
share the results of that learning and
then work off that results of that
learning the more we can share that
strong alerting information and that
learning
the more we can all analyze it as a
collective to be able to
evolve
and that will allow us to be continuous
and to evolve
i want to leave though with the one
thought here
we're not advocating to get rid of
humans in this
mix we're not advocating the replacement
of humans
we're advocating the augmentation of
humans to make
intelligent decisions so that we who
have this cognitive capability we who
can make leaps of intuition
can do the more interesting things
okay
what are your thoughts on where is going
to take you any questions that i can
answer we've got two and a half minutes
left
one of the things i've seen here today
is
the infrastructure the the cloud you
have is a dynamic beast you're
constantly adding and removing stuff
you get new customers you get new
workloads
it's
when you're training an ai if you change
any parameters you might
not have the result that you're looking
for and that that's the biggest
challenge that we have today because we
don't have static environments to train
in
what we're finding and a lot of the
conversations i've been having with with
researchers in the space nick is one of
those people
is
we have to set up environments that are
static to do that initial training
the trick is then moving that those
formulas into more dynamic environments
and monitoring them and that is that
core where i made the comments about
taking six eight ten weeks to train a
model
reality is you could train a model for
two years and you still wouldn't catch
every single possible parameter so
really good point
anything else otherwise i'm just going
to throw a hat into space and see if you
all jump and scrabble for them
i think silence all right well thank you
very much appreciate you coming in to
listen i hope i didn't bore anybody and
put anybody to sleep
um enjoy the rest of the summit and
we'll see you all around
[Applause]